en la región de almería al sur de
andalucía se encuentra lo que se conoce
como el mar de plástico
32 mil hectáreas de cultivos de frutas y
verduras en invernaderos que se pueden
ver desde el espacio estas láminas de
plástico están provocando un desastre
ecológico como la advierte este
activista
bueno esto es la serrata de dejar un
espacio natural y en cualquier sitio te
puedes encontrar un vertido del plástico
esto se debe a que estos invernaderos
son de un solo uso y se cambian después
de la cosecha anual el 15% son
abandonados por algunos agricultores los
desechos son depositados o enterrados en
el desierto porque de 32.000 hectáreas
de invernaderos que hay en almería un 15
por ciento un 10 por ciento son ya a
3000 4000 5.000 hectáreas de plástico
eso es grandes cantidades grandes
montañas de plástico
plástico contaminado con pesticidas que
se está deshaciendo esto es plástico un
micro plástico es no ya el tamaño nano
plásticos prácticamente podemos estar
contaminando nuestros propios productos
que exportamos a europa o que nos
comemos nosotros pero las primeras
víctimas de estos desechos son los
trabajadores de los invernaderos
migrantes ilegales que a menudo son
explotados y no declarados ellos mismos
han construido casas improvisadas en
medio de las hectáreas de plástico mikel
miembro de un sindicato de trabajadores
los visita
qué vergüenza y plásticos
y estos plásticos los sacan de de los
invernaderos
estos trabajadores llevan 20 años
viviendo en estos barrios pobres no hay
luz no hay asientos
hemos visto ahora que les han retirado
incluso la recogida de basura al igual
que esté ghanés hay 3000 personas que
viven en malas condiciones
las condiciones de vida no son buenas
aquí todo está degradado mira hay
plástico allá allá y allá también es más
ampliamente toda la flora y la fauna se
ven afectados por este flagelo cuando el
plástico se deshace este vuela
directamente al mediterráneo la
universidad de almería ha estudiado las
desastrosas consecuencias para la vida
marina cuando ver como la fibra son la
lana abundante tanto a cetáceos como
empecé como en portugal mayor una
particularidad de la región es que en
sus estómagos se encuentran fibras del
mar de plástico hace unos meses incluso
una tortuga fue encontrada muerta salió
completamente llenarla
plástico blando de bolsas de basura
plásticos también invernaderos plásticos
de un montón de tipos pero él crea más
de 5 kilos lo que tenían en su estómago
un ejemplo que se ha convertido en algo
común a lo largo de los años este tipo
de plásticos se presentan mucho entonces
claro por todo lo que es la radiación el
mar etcétera no pues sabemos que si
tienen efectos dañinos en nuestro en
nuestra salud estos micro plásticos se
detectan cada vez más en el cuerpo
humano e incluso provocan trastornos
endocrinos sin embargo este mar de
plástico produce cada vez más frutas y
verduras frescas para europa desde hace
40 años
cada año se cultivan 3 millones de
toneladas de frutas y hortalizas
constantino produce tomates y peras
ecológicos es un buen estudiante recicla
todo el plástico de sus invernaderos 7
hectáreas en total algunos tipos de
plásticos son más costosos de tratar que
otros los plásticos de las
organizaciones y los dobles techos es un
plástico que tiene menos valor porque no
tiene goma y ese hay ocasiones que
tienes que pagar
porque se los gastos de transporte para
que una empresa recoja y trate la luna
usada desde digo a los jóvenes es tarea
constante puede costar 50 euros que se
lo lleven en la planta no te cuesta más
según él a los agricultores se les suele
culpar del problema cuando en realidad
intentan protegerlo
no es complicado y tortuoso desidia de
unos pocos cuando algunos vamos a una
minoría lo mismo ocurre con los centros
especializados en la gestión de residuos
este ayuda a procesar las 33.000
toneladas de plástico que se generan
cada año pues este práctico que son
residuos de los invernaderos pontes de
esto pues acaba una vez reciclado en una
materia prima para hacer frente a este
enorme reto estas empresas de reciclaje
se han desarrollado muy recientemente ha
sido generalmente pues no se utilizaban
para reciclarlo sino que había alguna
empresa que se la llevaba afuera
y acabado
hace tres años china luego pakistán
india y turquía dejaron de importar este
plástico que antes reciclaban para
evitar pagar precios elevados en españa
algunas explotaciones prefieren recurrir
a empresas poco escrupulosas
nos olvidamos de un factor que a
nosotros no hace muchos años que sólo
que nosotros denominamos los
transportistas ilegales que directamente
van al invernadero cobran por el residuo
y no tienen capacidad para gestionarla
desde el pasado otoño el gobierno
andaluz ha empezado a poner multas pero
estas no disuaden a los agricultores que
están detrás de los basureros ilegales
pues estas multas no permiten el cierre
de las explotaciones